diane what's going on hi how you guys
doing
we are have the time of our life how
about you
not quite so that's why i'm so glad i
was in contact with you guys
hey i'm so glad you called so what's up
how can i help
i'm 53 years old i'm single
i grew up very poor okay
two girls out of wedlock they're grown
now okay
i was on um government assistance for
years okay i'm trying to calm down i
want to pass out on the phone
hey you are okay you're doing incredible
you're doing incredible
i did not have any guidance
no self-confidence no self-esteem
yeah you name it
i've come upon a great job with benefits
and i'm just so overwhelmed i'm so
gracious for having this job
yeah again i never had any guidance on
how to handle money
i trusted this co-worker to tell me how
to go about
to getting more money
that was the worst mistake i made in my
life
i'm so sorry and this co-worker steal
from you or give you some kind of scheme
or something like that
yeah it was a scheme and i ran
with it yeah and now i'm in debt
okay hey diane yeah
i've done the same thing no
yes ma'am 100 of the people listening to
this show have done the same thing
whether the scheme was a leased car or
stupid credit cards
or hey give me a hundred dollars and
i'll turn it into a thousand dollars to
give me ten thousand dollars to 100
i do not know a person who hasn't made
mistakes with money
and i want you to know you're not by
yourself on this one okay
okay all right all right so keep going
so you you did something dumb now you
got
now you got debt okay now
i um let's say i have a car that i had
it was
21 years old and so working this job i
was able to
purchase a 2015 model car look at you
man hey my car's a twenty no
mine's a 2006 diane you're crushing it
i'm gonna buy your car from you all
right so you got it you got a
a new used car you're just yeah you're a
new youth car i'm still paying on it
okay
and i'm trying and i went into my
retirement savings to try to catch up
with the bills that i owe
to try to reduce that amount of
when i'm in dead end and so it seems
like i'm piling
more and more money right and keep that
instead of
okay hey hey i just made a mess you did
you did
okay you made a mess and you called you
called the cleanup crew
all right
you hear me yes tell me about this job
you got you said you just stumbled upon
it i don't believe that for a second i
think you're i
in my younger days i knew about the job
i played softball and i knew about the
jobs they had like lance and continental
tires the people
that i'll play softball with yeah but i
didn't know how
i didn't have a computer i know how to
to get into the job
but now i'm with the post office yeah
look at that hey
you guys saved our lives during covet i
know
and boy we worked out our behinds off
for you guys you had to get your mail
and prescriptions i knew my prescription
had to get my books had to get food
everything and plus all the other stuff
that we bought just because it made us
feel good
right yeah yeah okay
so let's do this i want to back out a
second okay
let's pull this apart and we'll do it
pretty quickly how much money do you
make a year
it varies okay give me a ballpark
i could make from 50 000 to 100
000 if i wanted to by doing overtime all
right
okay how much debt do you have if you
took every single penny you owe somebody
else how much is that
a hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars
all right so here's the way we like to
uh
i work here at ramsey solutions my boss
is dave ramsey
um here's here's the language that he
uses that i love
you got a big hole right you got 130
2 000 hole and
you work like bananas for two years you
work like
a somebody that i know you can you've
been working hard your whole life
you got a big shovel too
right and you can dig out of this hole
in relatively short fashion
and along the way you're gonna stand up
taller
you're going to learn a whole bunch of
new things so the next time some
knucklehead co-worker comes to you
you're going to
laugh at them and go idiot ain't getting
my mind here
right um or you're going to take him out
to coffee because i'm i would say idiot
you're
more compassionate and kind than me you
take him out to coffee and you're gonna
say hey
you're leave you're doing this sideways
okay
okay but listen it feels like a lot
right now and it is
and you are in a great position to crush
it
and not only crush it but i know i know
i know diane at your office
you're the kind of person that people
come ask for things aren't they
yes yep you are a
strong brilliant powerful person who's
been through a lot in life
and my guess is the peace that you walk
through a room
at work people gravitate towards you
yes you know and you're still positive
am i right
yes okay so true so this is just
another one you're not going to beat
yourself up over it
hey i'll just tell you mine was about
100 i think it was 117
000 was how big my hole was okay i had
to dig out
dave's was millions okay
so if you're sitting next to old man
dave ramsey he gonna laugh at the size
of your hole here's
okay okay now here's what this means
you're gonna have to get on a plan
you're gonna have to get a budget you
have to be on a plan you're gonna have
to get a group of people around you
they're gonna hold you accountable and
walk alongside you
and most importantly you're gonna have
to change your entire psychology around
money
around dying around who you are okay
you got it you are strong and powerful
and you just need some new information
and you're gonna be off to the races
okay okay so here's what i'm gonna do
for you number one
i'm gonna give you for free i'm gonna
give you my book
it's on it's called um redefining
anxiety
in someone in your situation this idea
of i screwed up this idea of
my past traumas this idea of money makes
me nervous
now um people coming to you with schemes
gonna make you
your heart takes off on you right your
heart starts beating fast or you get
that stomach drops
that you know that's that warm feeling
in your belly like i failed something
yeah i'm gonna give you this book and
i'm gonna give it to you for free that's
number one
number two i'm gonna send you a copy of
dave ramsey's total money makeover book
for free
okay and that's going to walk you
through everything
hey i'm not done yet i'm going to send
you ramsey plus
for a year it's our subscription service
here's what it is
it's got financial peace university the
gentle
step-by-step course it's nine lessons
they're digital lessons you can get
online and watch them in your house
invite your friends over they're
entertaining they're fun but they are
lessons on
why we do what we do step by step by
step
it also comes with a community whether
that's in person classes or online
classes
where you can talk through people's
journeys you can
watch all these things and it comes with
the app
the most important app i it's what i use
in my house
it tracks my money it connects to my
bank my wife and i can use it together
all of it together i want you to invite
your daughters in on this because i want
this to be a moment for you
that's what i was just telling them i
won't i don't want them to make the same
there you go
you know what that word is legacy you're
going to change your family tree
and it's not too late and your grandkids
are going to live different lives
because you put a stick in the ground
at 53 years old and said no more from my
family
you know what i'm saying you know and
listen
then you're gonna get all you're gonna
go berserker about it
and then people at your church are gonna
be like why are you suddenly six foot
six tall
why you got all these fancy new clothes
that you're paying for in cash and
you're gonna say i'm gonna run a class
at my church
on my own and then they're gonna it's
gonna sell out and you're gonna look
people in the eye who are
feeling just like you are right now and
you're going to help them stand up tall
you're going to hug them tight you're
going to say you've got a big hole
but you're going to get a big shovel
we're going we're going to work our way
through this right
but i'm such an honest person let me
tell you this okay
i went on to mr ramsey's site
and i saw that he had uh
the trial and i've already
told me i'm already on step two yep
which i didn't know
you know at least i have the thousands
saved there you go
see you only got seven more to go seven
more to go
and listen hey i i i'm you don't need
the child anymore i'm gonna give it to
you for a year
okay no more trials i'm gonna give it to
you but listen
um you're gonna you are gonna have to
work hard for two years
probably probably two and a half maybe i
thought it was gonna be
longer but it's only gonna be two years
you're talking hey
it's a math problem that means you're
going to have to be on rice and beans
ain't going to be no more diane going
partying every night i know you don't do
that anyway
i grew up pouring so they won't yeah
that's what i'm saying and you're going
to pick up every overtime shift you got
you're going to embarrass those 26 year
olds when they say the words
i'm so tired you're going to look at
them and go come on now
and then you're going to say well cool
give me your shift because i'm going to
get paid
i'm going to get paid i'm going to get
paid and you're going to have something
to work towards
work towards or towards diane i want you
to say this out loud
i'm gonna change my family tree i'm
gonna change my family tree
starting today start today
and here's the thing diane here's what
happens when you make that decision
is millions of people listening to this
right now
are going to be driving okay millions
that's probably a little bit
overstatement maybe 38 people listen as
podcast
right they're driving down the road
they're mowing their yard they're
vacuuming their house they are going for
a run whatever they're doing
they just stopped and they said diane
she can change the family tree i'm going
to also and it starts with getting
control of your money
your thoughts your actions getting in
relationships with other people who are
good for you who aren't going to steal
from you
or aren't going to sucker you into
something
and you're going to have some
generational traumas you're going to
work through dying this can be a whole
process but you're going to start with
now you're on baby step two you're gonna
lay out all those debts you're gonna
follow a plan you're gonna take a little
step and a little step in a little step
you're gonna bring your kids with you
you're gonna bring your friends with you
you're talking about an entire new
legacy you're going to take those bricks
out of your backpack and you're going to
pave a new road
that your grandkids are going to walk on
and they're going to remember about
grandma diane
and how she said no more 53 changed at
all i'm so proud of you for making this
call
i'm proud of you for saying no more for
being vulnerable and saying how
i finally after 50 years
i got me a great job and then i went
stepped in
cha-cha again that's cool we're gonna
hose our boots off and we're gonna keep
going
i'm so proud of you diane man yeah this
is this is why i love this show because
i hang up the phone
and i'm motivated i get motivated
to continue to work those little tiny
tiny steps tiny steps tiny steps
towards changing my family tree thank
you so much diane for this call